all right sam worthington you may have
taken out the Kraken in Clash of the
Titans but you're going up against a
Titan in this one so you're gonna need a
good solid mullet if you're gonna pull
okay all right check on the mullet let's
take out a titan wrath of the Titans
okay if any of you remember my review of
Clash of the Titans was not a big fan
the post converted 3d hurt my eyes the
movie was choppy I just didn't think it
was good so I went into wrath of the
Titans thinking I was going to come out
of it set up my camera and just tear
this movie apart
someone wrath of the Titans Sam
Worthington once again plays Perseus now
rocking a nice sweet mullet there which
actually makes him feel more like
Perseus I don't know why it's amazing
how a haircut can change the entire vibe
of a character and maybe a movie for
that matter regardless it's a few years
later he has his kid he just wants to
settle down be a fisherman but you know
some of the gods have other plans
long story short Hades is going to
unleash the Titan Kronos onto the world
that's pretty much a bad day for
humanity as in like all of it now
Perseus must stop it so now I'll let you
know wrath of the Titans actually
surprisingly entertained me I'm not
saying the movie was perfect I'm just
saying what I was looking for when I
went into Clash of the Titans was more
found in wrath of the Titans something
that had badass action movie wasn't so
choppy there were a couple of parts for
me
alright the movie's slowing down let's
pick it I'll rise sweet you picked it up
once again you got Liam Neeson being
Zusi he's not much of a douchebag in
this movie you know in Clash of the
Titans he was the dick and at the end II
kind of chilled out this one he is like
a good guy and it's Liam Neeson the dude
is made to play deities on film in fact
when he plays a god character I don't
think he even knows he's being filmed
it's like a documentary for Liam Neeson
at this point Clash of the Titans and
wrath of the Titans played Zeus a god
the Narnia movies Aslan Jesus God
metaphor taken he played the Lord you
know I'm right I can say this the gods
and wrath of the Titans actually feel
like you know great gods how you would
think they'd be they don't look like
Ambercrombie models or anything like
that so there is that in the movie and
now we get to see Ares the God of War is
some about him I just thought Ares was a
puss I mean God of War factor aside in
the end I just had daddy issues side
note though doesn't he look like me and
Jesus like if we lived in an alternate
dimension where there was a movie where
the Jeremy Sisto Jesus suddenly
like a mean dude be buoyed by that guy I
more prefer Ares with the big flaming
beard from God award that's a good Aries
right there face on fire Aries good
stuff but other than the movie stepping
up the action I actually liked how they
touched on some of the messed up family
dynamic because that's what Greek
mythology is it's really just one big
cluster of family drama and they
touched on a couple of aspects of that
and actually a really good way surprise
me for sure granted this elements what
took the nerf bat to Aries making the
God of War look like a wuss with daddy
issues but it was good for the movie as
a whole I will say wrath of the Titans
is a good time no alcohol required to my
everlasting surprise now I couldn't see
the movie in 3d or I would have seen it
in 3d so I can tell you how shitty the
converted 3d was but I could only watch
it in 2d it was almost like the movie
theater was like we don't have the heart
to put you through another converted
Titans movie so you get to D only so if
you're gonna see wrath of the Titans see
and 2d if you elect to pay more for
converted 3d when you have the option of
2d Hades is gonna come out of nowhere
and punch you in the taints just don't
do that so I'm pretty sure in my review
of immortals I asked you what your
favorite Greek mythology movie was so
want to ask it again so what's your
favorite Liam Neeson movie I might have
asked that before but the dude always
plays God whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you